wednesday shireen let's focus first
though on the one i didn't mention
buccaneers receiver chris godwin that
was a surprise
to me
because
i thought the tag was going to go to
shaq barrett i thought it was going to
be shaq barrett tagged
linebacker pass rusher it would have
been the second time for him at 18.99
million or long-term deal for barrett
and godwin tagged what we got is godwin
tagged
no tag for barrett obviously you got one
per team and no deal yet we reported
earlier today via twitter i don't think
i wrote this but we reported on twitter
that
they're talking to shaq barrett about a
long-term deal but their leverage went
out the window their ability to block
them from the market went out the window
because as of now
he can walk away in eight days and sign
with anyone he wants and that's a risky
move for the tampa bay buccaneers
because i think that shaq barrett's a
lot more important to that team frankly
in all due respect to chris godwin than
godwin is
you know what it tells you mike it tells
me something we already knew it just
confirms it tom brady is firmly in
charge of this organization he has a
hand he has a say it's his team it's his
face of the organization i guarantee you
he wanted chris godwin back so the bucks
made sure chris godwin was coming back
there they have so much depth at
receiver there was no need to apply the
tag let chris godwin walk away you've
got tyler johnson you've
got
scottie miller you've got of course mike
evans you've got plenty receivers you
can resign a b for less money tons of
options there at receiver but mike they
better get shaq barrett resigned or they
better find a pass rusher because he is
the guy i don't know that the bucks
would have won the super bowl without
shaq barrett when you look at the four
sacks and the eight quarterback
pressures that he had in the last two
games the nfc championship game and the
super bowl they could not have done it
without him he was a big part of that
and they have no one else to rush the
passer like shaq barrett can brush the
passer so they either need to resign him
or find someone else to replace him
which may be even more costly to get
this thing done and have a chance at a
repeat
now maybe they're looking at this year's
free agency class and this was something
that dawned on me not that long ago
looking at some of the depth charts we
were going through yesterday the teams
in the nfc west
and
which defenders are better than j.j
water which defenders would you rather
have and my god the number of free
agents and will leak wide the number of
pass rushers do to become free agents
maybe they're thinking look we got shaq
barrett on a one-year deal from the
denver broncos two years ago and it
worked out we'll go get someone else
like that we've got vitaveya on the
inside we've got jpp on the other side
maybe they bring back in dominican soup
maybe they're just realizing that shaq
barrett too rich for the buccaneers
blood and you know the reality is they
tag him this year and he said i want to
break the bank they tag him this year
and he's like the other guys who have
been tagged for a second time justin
simmons brandon surf etc long-term deal
by july 15 or walks away next year
because next year the third tag for
non-quarterbacks the tag becomes
quarterback money or a 44 bump so
there's no way he was going to get
tagged a third time and now the question
is will he stay and if not who are they
targeting to replace him and maybe
there's somebody out there they already
have an eye on look it would be naive to
assume
that in not tagging shaq barrett the
buccaneers don't have a plan for
replacing him i don't think let's see
what happens is the plan that the
buccaneers have hatched here shireen
no probably not mike and let's not be
naive either i mean we know the
negotiating period doesn't start for a
little bit but let's be honest they've
already talked agents have talked they
know where teams stand they know who's
interested in their players
you know we all know that they're naive
to think that doesn't happen so i i
firmly believe they have a plan but
whatever their plan is they better make
sure it works and they better lock up
one of these guys i like shaq barry and
think he fits their defense perfectly i
mean the 19 and a half sacks last season
was fanta i mean 2019 was fantastic he
followed that up with eight sacks this
year and as i said it was so important
in that playoff run for the buccaneers i
just think he's a big part of what they
do so i would hope that they would try
to get him back we know they resigned
levante david today to a two-year deal
they've agreed to so they did get one of
those pieces back on their defense they
need shaq barrett bat too in my opinion
and let me tell you levante david is not
signing the two-year extension to stay
with the buccaneers unless he has looked
around and found out what else is out
there it happens it's tampering
sometimes tampering helps a team because
in this case the fact if it happened and
it would have been malpractice frankly
by levante david's agent if it didn't
happen if david called around browns for
example were linked to david well okay
let's have a hypothetical conversation
if if hypothetically a veteran
linebacker who hypothetically plays for
a team in tampa and hypothetically has
been there since 2012 hypothetically
becomes available what hypothetically
would you be willing to pay there's a
way to find out and you find out what's
behind door number one and door number
two before you accept what's behind
either door that's probably if not
likely what happened here and it helped
the buccaneers gauging the market it's
it's okay for the agents to do it it's
tampering for the teams to do it it
happens all the time the problem is
every once in a while something falls
into the nfl's lap and they whack
somebody for it just kind of arbitrarily
like the chiefs a few years ago when god
forbid andy reid spoke directly to
jeremy macklin at the time when he was
only allowed to speak to macklin's agent
to negotiate a contract so that's the
risk but the reward can be
for the team
that has the guy under contract the guy
knows
that it's better for him to stay put
where he is two more years for levante
david now
i think with shaq barrett it's entirely
possible sharim that he wants so much
because he used that line in one of his
radio visits after the super bowl he
wants to break the bank
maybe they know he wants so much he's
not going to get it so maybe maybe this
is one where
you let him go see what's out there and
he realizes that what he wants isn't out
there so
come back on a one-year deal just like
two years ago you know maybe get the
same amount he would have gotten under
the franchise tag last year not a 20
bump something incentive based based on
sacks whatever and then he can become a
free agent again in 2022 when the salary
cap goes up so
it's not over yet but it is surprising
that the tag was applied the god one
and barrett doesn't have a deal but
they've got godwin they've got david
they hope to get barrett
they i think would like to keep in
dominic and sue but they're chipping
away at keeping the band together it's
still going to take some time and effort
to make it happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports